passion de stockage et oui et
aujourd'hui nouvelle vidéo du monde
c'est squeeze aujourd'hui on se retrouve
de nouveau sur un jeu pourri alors bon
c'était un peu une semaine spéciale je
pourrais on a eu deux la lie quand on a
eu du sumo et là on a de la caissière
tout simplement
alors pourquoi j'ai une vidéo sur ce jeu
parce que vous avez été je dirais
peut-être 15 à m'envoyer un lien d'un
site qui propose ce jeu donc soit c'est
connu et moi je connais pas ou soit
quelqu'un déjà fait une vidéo dessus ou
quoi ce qui m'étonnerait pas bref en
tout cas c'est parti ou comme quoi que
je dis tu ouvres tweets
eh ben j'ai fais ok vas faire de
l'edough dessus y vole c'est parti
l'argent peut noter juste là le super
realistic simulation que oui ce 3d real
time ce genre genre attention c'est une
simulation de balade et le bruit des
bruits faits maison et cool alors c'est
parti on va jouer à ce jeu j'ai vu les
touche juste en haut à droite au nom
j'ai oublié les rues tabacalera zut
merde aux jolies et et je t'embrasse et
le patron puisqu'il sa première pour s&p
/ espace où je vais retourner avec les
flèches mais attends lamentable et des
smartphones comme pardon mais dis donc
noirot mal à l'aise on continue ça fera
9 13 99 99 euros s'il vous plaît
d'accord ouais je l'air regrettez pas
aventure c'est mieux que colloque à a
il ya même du trollage attention c'est
que tout ce qu'il achète lui au jard ya
une mégastar faith dessus tout assez des
chocolats bas
via la bastille qu'au dessus épique vers
l or 4 6 1 4 4 023 2,4 et bon lamentable
e chili chili chili con carne est
quelqu'un de calme carnet way avec un
mix café du banjo la montagne naturel
sans colorant sans conservateur sans
ammoniaque sans user essentielle de
chameau sans gras sans ordures ménagères
et ce en kryptonite burger si le regarde
superman ou et ça va je passe pas trois
heures inspecté produits j'aime bien le
bras vous savez j'en reviens acheter
jusqu'à la gueule
oh oh oh débats jusqu'à des messieurs ça
tout ce qui à mes yeux magnifiques yeux
car j'ai trouvé un glitch nul audio
n'est pas tus et onair tout ça il ya une
équipe de 300 mec qui bosse jour et nuit
pendant une semaine jean monnet complexe
de caisse je ne me serais de l'année
wecht à vue wiley n'était de pervers un
espèce de petit gros comme par hasard
dans ce jeu y'a plein de code barres qui
ne marche pas tu sais en magasin il ya
comme moi les top 25 qui ne marche pas
un mais je kiffe saison je parie qu'ils
quitteraient journée as tu vois là
nouveaux jeux achetés au cdi ladies and
gentleman molik hôtesse de caisse en
plus ils ont bien fait le patron jean
legros patron mais genre la grosse
[ __ ] devant son ordi en mode normal
naturel des cagnottes jusqu'à bayard je
trouve mon futur métier tu sûr en pack
pro qu'est ce qu'ils ont ce jeu là en
fait ça toute la journée tu vas encore
tu joues à 5 heures de suite bon allez
on finit l on voit juste la télé celui
d'après et je pense que cette vidéo
prendre à sa fin sur une vidéo bonus
dans le jeu nul de la semaine entière oh
oui puisqu à d'accord donc en fait c'est
à dire que cette question est vraiment
génial
elle presse des articles elle va bouffer
tu attends une heure et demie debout à
la caisse avec un gros sourire de beauce
hier et un gros sourire forcé au mode
c'est quand y revient faut arrêter je
veux maintenant vos yeux saigne alors je
continue je pose mon séjour à finir le
ch et moi je vais quitter l'aj quitter
les jeux quitté l'école pour devenir
caissier et hayden tête via un mode
j'aime tes fesses il hier au 1
attention il ya quelque chose c'est la
fin de journée dormir un peu dormir un
peu pour voir deux mois bon retour à la
maison c'est tout j'ai fini je me
moquais durée de vie cinq minutes
déçu je suis déçu quoi déçu et la main
est plus belle que la main de la fille
qu'on voit sur la photo g cham christine
sioui les télécharger sur la description
on se retrouve bientôt pour de nouvelles
vidéos ben on va un peu stoppé jeu
pourri un peut-être on va essayer de
faire vidéo sur un vrai jeu un de trop
longtemps ça ferait du bien tu veux te
monfils à bientôt
pis
m